Trascrizione: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Michele Gianella
(Canta)
Tutti!
Forte!
Benvenuti a tutti, grazie, è un piacere.
Sono Javier Romero, arrivo dalla Spagna,
e parlo l'itagnolo, come hai visto.
Il modello è molto chiaro:
è l’Africa, non la Finlandia.
Sì, io ho fatto un sacco di ricerca
in Ghana, in Burkina Faso,
in Senegal, in Namibia.
E la cosa più importante per me
è mostrare che il corpo è importantissimo.
Il corpo è lo strumento più antico
che noi abbiamo, per fare musica.
Lo posso fare tramite le mani,
con il clapping, con i piedi,
con il torace, con tutto.
Questo è molto importante per noi,
perché il corpo non ha una parte razionale
[bensì] di sensazione, di stimolazione.
Questo è importantissimo,
ed è quello che voglio trasmettere oggi.
Però, la cosa ancora più interessante
è che c'è anche la stimolazione cognitiva:
il lobo frontale,
tutto ciò che noi facciamo,
dove l’attenzione, concentrazione,
pianificazione, sequenziazione,
controllo di impulsi,
è sempre stimolata
[dal] nostro cervello.
Facciamo una piccola prova,
che è molto interessante.
Alziamo la mano destra tutti,
tutti con la mano destra sopra.
Benissimo.
Sotto, sotto, sopra, a destra, benissimo!
Sopra, sotto, a sinistra,
sopra, sotto, a destra,
sopra, sotto, destra, sopra, sotto,
posizione orizzontale: tutti orizzontale.
Ho detto orizzontale, questo è verticale!
Che è successo?
(Risate)
Questo è importante.
Questo si chiama
"resistenza all’interferenza"
ed è importantissimo.
Io ti ho dato un codice
di lavoro, di movimento,
prodotto con la visione:
con il movimento,
te lo posso cambiare subito.
Adesso con due mani,
lo facciamo tutti con due mani.
Benissimo, benissimo.
Io dico una lettera, per esempio A,
devi fare un clapping.
A, A, A
B.
Ahi!!
(Risate)
Grazie!
A, A,
M!
C!
OK, adesso aggiungiamo.
A: clapping; B: cosce con due mani.
Attenzione: preparati?
Sì, nessuno dorme: è fantastico.
A, B,
M,
A, S, R, B,
A, C, A, R, B,
C: con la gamba destra.
Preparati, preparati!
A, B, C, CBA.
OK.
A, R, S, B,
A, C, C, A.
Che è successo?
Benissimo, resistenza all’interferenza.
Questo è importantissimo:
una parte visuale ti può fare
una stimolazione molto, molto forte
e per quello così per noi è il corpo,
e la visione che noi abbiamo
è importantissima.
Come lo facciamo? Con il movimento.
Ti voglio stimolare, e darti
degli strumenti super importanti
per sapere come muovere
il corpo, così a poco a poco.
E lo facciamo [anche]
con la nuova tecnologia;
io viaggio [spesso] in Africa.
e faccio sempre una cosa:
viaggio anche con l'iPad,
faccio una foto alla tribù
e [gliela] giro e si guardano subito.
E cosa succede? Questo.
Riflessione, per noi della nostra epoca:
la fotografia [serviva a] ricordare.
Oggi, per la nuova generazione
[serve a] comunicare.
E questo è molto molto importante,
per la stimolazione con il movimento,
con un pensiero africano,
è anche importantissimo.
Ci alziamo tutti, ci alziamo:
in piedi, in piedi.
Benissimo.
Tutte le mani, tutti così.
Perfetto, perfetto, perfetto.
[Alzate le due mani], benissimo.
Ok, [riuscite a] vedermi?
Perfetto, perché adesso facciamo:
un, due, ta ta ta racatatatun, one, two!
Clap, clap, cosce, piedi, piedi;
clap, clap, e clap clap;
e cosce, piedi, clap, clap,
torace, cosce, e piedi.
Non [fermiamoci] qui, non fermatevi!
Avanti, avanti! Più forte, più forte!
Forte il piede.
Il piede, forte!
Fantastico, siete bravissimi!
Non ti puoi fermare, continua!
Continua, perfetto!
Stop, stop, stop!
Con me!
Forte il piede!
Forte!
Uno, due, tre, stop.
Uno, due, tutti insieme!
Perfetto: ancora, ancora,
senza problemi, perfetto, perfetto!
Attenzione, attenzione.
Da ora in poi solo cosce, solo cosce.
Adesso!
Silenzio tutti!
Solo cosce, adesso.
Avanti!
E stop!
Un applauso, l'hanno fatto
tutti molto bene.
(Applausi)
Perfetto. No, no, tutti in piedi!
Benissimo.
E adesso il movimento super importante,
perché adesso arriva
una parte importantissima per noi,
che si chiama stimolazione cognitiva.
Su questo io ho la sensazione
che con l'Africa
c'è sempre un doppio senso.
Un doppio senso che ogni volta
che [l’hai pensato] come il terzo mondo,
io ho pensato quasi sempre che forse,
quando viaggio in Africa, c'è il futuro.
Perché abbiamo una struttura di vita, qua,
che è tutta frammentata,
e di là io vedo
che è tutto unito e collegato.
Adesso io lo faccio
nella seguente maniera.
Vediamo che c’è un piccolo quadrato,
il quadrato che vedi qua, che è questo.
Devi fare, semplicemente:
uno, due, tre e quattro.
Avanti, avanti, indietro e indietro.
Avanti, avanti, indietro, avanti,
avanti, indietro e avanti, avanti…
Preparati per la stimolazione cognitiva,
del tuo livello [di attenzione].
Mamma mia!
E one, two, clap sull’uno.
Adesso!
Solo sull'uno!
Uno, due!
Solo due!
Solo due.
Adesso.
Due!
Solo all’uno.
E solo al tre!
Solo al tre! Uno, due, solo al tre.
Quattro.
Perfetto!
Uno, due!
Uno due!
Solo uno!
Adesso cantiamo una canzone
molto, molto conosciuta
che dice:
"Fra Martino, campanaro,
dormi tu, dormi tu.
Suona le campane,
suona le campane, din, don, dan!"
Clap, uno, due!
Fra Martino, solo uno!
Dormi tu, dormi tu,
suona le campane,
suona le campane din, don, dan!
E stop!
Un applauso: lo [avete] fatto
molto bene, perfetto.
No, no, in piedi, in piedi.
Preparati.
Benissimo.
Adesso devi alzare la mano destra:
si alza la mano destra, perfetto.
La mano destra ha
un nuovo nome, si chiama "Ta".
Come si chiama la mano destra?
(Pubblico): Ta.
JR: Benissimo!
Sempre a domanda, una risposta.
Se io ti dico "Ta" cosa mi devi dire tu?
(Pubblico):Ta!
Benissimo: però devi anche fare
un piccolo movimento, devi strisciare.
Prima lo faccio io, poi tu.
Sarebbe: Ta, Ta, Tatata.
Tatata, Ta, Ta.
Ta, Ta, Tata.
L'altra mano!
Preparati, si chiama "Ki"
Ki, ki, kikiki!
Ta, ta, chi, chi.
Tatata, ki ki.
Ta, ki, tatata ki.
E adesso arriva il Mambo N°5,
perché lo devi fare con un quadrato!
Sì, preparati: hai mangiato bene?
Benissimo, tutti in quadrato: one, two!
Balliamo in quadrato;
uno e due, dietro e dietro;
avanti e avanti, dietro e indietro.
Attenzione, è divisa: due compiti, sì.
Per le donne questo è facilissimo:
sono capace di fare
28 cose - sì, perfetto.
Avanti, e avanti; indietro, e indietro.
Ta, ta, tatata!
(Pubblico): ta, ta, tatata!
JR: tatata, tatata!
(Pubblico): tatata, tatata!
JR: Ki, ki.. kiki!
(Pubblico): Ki, ki.. kiki!
JR: Ta, Ki, Ta, Ki!
(Pubblico): Ta, Ki, Ta, Ki!
Adesso tutti super-preparati:
non si ferma il piede,
non si ferma mai, mai.
Devi prendere le mani della coppia:
perfetto, perfetto.
L'hai fatto virtualmente:
adesso, devi stringere la mano destra.
Avanti, avanti; e indietro, e indietro;
e avanti, avanti; e indietro, indietro,
Tutti preparati?
Attenzione, attenzione:
Ta, ta, tatata. Destra!
(Pubblico): Ta, ta, tatata.
JR: Ki, Ki, Kikiki!
(Pubblico): Ki, Ki, Kikiki!
Preparati: Ta, ki, ta, ki!
(Pubblico): Ta, ki, ta, ki!
JR: Takitaki, ta ta ta Ki!
(Pubblico): Tatata, ta ta Ki!
JR: Tatata, kikiki!
(Pubblico): Tatata, kikiki!
E un applauso, l'avete fatto molto bene!
(Applauso)
Benissimo.
Perfetto.
Lo hanno fatto molto, molto bene.
Questo è molto importante per noi,
perché la stimolazione che noi abbiamo
tramite il corpo è importantissima.
Perché abbiamo visto che se facciamo
delle piccole pillole di movimento,
con un alto livello
di concentrazione, di attenzione,
si può avere la stimolazione.
Noi lavoriamo moltissimo con persone sane,
e anche con persone
con Parkinson, Alzheimer
e danni cerebrali: ictus etc.
Questo è molto importante per noi,
perché sappiamo che con
questo tipo di attività
c'è una cosa molto importante:
che l'apprendimento è ludico.
È la cosa più importante:
non [riesco a] imparare, quando soffro.
C'è un momento dove io posso imparare,
però c'è una gioia,
c'è un livello di ossitocina,
la ghiandola pituitaria
che stimola un sacco di ormoni.
È per questo che ciò
che abbiamo qua, il lobo frontale,
è una parte - è molto,
molto sviluppata, questa parte,
per pianificare, sequenziare
ciò che io ho imparato
ad avere semplicemente
un controllo d'impulso.
E un'altra cosa super-interessante:
il movimento e la pianificazione
di quello che io devo fare
dipende anche dal mio comportamento,
e anche con la società.
Per quello noi, sempre,
abbiamo la sensazione
che prima sente il corpo,
dopo arriva la testa.
Prima sento; e dopo arriva
la parte razionale, la parte cognitiva,
la parte dove io penso al 100%.
Questo è molto importante,
perché il movimento che sempre facciamo
deve essere collegato
a una parte di stimolazione
della estremità superiore,
l'estremità inferiore;
e soprattutto con la voce.
E noi abbiamo fatto una ricerca gigantesca
sempre con la scuola media, elementare
e anche soprattutto con persone
con diversi tipi di patologia
per provare a stimolare
e fare ricerca, dare un aiuto.
Senza la pillola,
e soprattutto nella forma
più naturale al 100 percento.
Quello che noi abbiamo fatto
è semplicemente una piccola introduzione
dove, sempre tramite la Body Percussion,
la neuromotricità insomma,
è importantissimo sapere
come si stimola il corpo,
perché lo posso fare
in una maniera molto strutturata.
Alla fine, la cosa più importante
che io voglio trasmettere
è che la forma sequenziale
di apprendimento
cambia in diverse culture.
La prima volta che io sono stato,
per esempio, in Burkina Faso,
in un una tribù che si chiama Navrongo,
ho visto un sacco di gente con i djembé.
Sono andato subito, e ho detto:
prendo anch'io un djembé,
e voglio anche imparare.
Sono andato là, e ho chiesto:
mi puoi insegnare?
Sì sì, non c'è problema, ok.
Lui mi dice: primo ritmo -
(Musica)
E io ho detto: stop, non posso farlo.
E come facciamo?
La mia risposta: lo facciamo.
E come facciamo? È la mia terra!
E lui mi dice: come è la tua terra?
La mia terra è che tu fai -
e io faccio -
e lui mi dice: no no no.
Questo te lo devi imparare
completo, integro.
Questo è impossibile.
Però se io vado a Granada, in Andalusia,
per imparare il flamenco,
non c'è un livello uno di bulería,
un livello due di bulería
e un livello tre, così, di bulería.
Apprendi la bulería
così com'è, con il flamenco;
però non è tutto frammentato.
E questo è super-importante.
E la cosa più curiosa
è che lui subito mi chiede: e te che fai?
Qual è la tua terra?
Qual è il tuo lavoro?
Io sono insegnante di musica.
(Risate)
Lui mi guarda, e io gli ho detto:
guarda, io faccio questo, sai.
È la mia vita.
Io mangio così, di questo.
Quando io gli ho detto
che io facevo musica,
per lui è stato come se insegnassi
ad andare al bar a bere il caffè.
Ossia la cosa più normale che ci fosse.
E questo lo ha colpito moltissimo,
perché ha visto che veramente la musica,
la parte cinestetica, il movimento,
era all'interno di una cultura
che [mentre tra di loro]
si trasmette giorno per giorno,
sempre, in tutti i momenti
della vita, in modo normale,
noi lo facciamo in una forma frammentata,
dove: devo andare a scuola;
che mi fa il ballo di ...;
e lo faccio con una struttura
molto [complessa].
Per questo è importantissimo per noi
sapere, e trasmettere,
che forse il modello non è Finlandia.
Il modello può essere l'Africa.
Il modello è l'Africa,
perché ha una cultura
di struttura molto chiara:
molto di gruppo, molto tribale,
di lavoro [collettivo]:
inclusiva, cooperativa,
non di competizione.
E questo è molto importante
per sapere, per creare
altri tipi di comunità
dove non c'è sempre una competizione.
La cosa più importante è, anche,
che il corpo diventa sempre
una forma della trasmissione
di come io mi sento, delle mie emozioni.
E la parte africana
mi aiuta sempre a farlo.
Mani sopra, facciamo così.
(Canta)
Tutti!
Forte!
Più forte!
Cosce, clapping!
Forte!
Piede!
(Applausi)
Per finire,
la parte più importante
per me, l'obiettivo finale
è [trasmettervi] che un insegnante
non trasmette il sapere,
ma solo la storia d'amore,
o di crepacuore,
che avete con la vostra disciplina.
E questa è la cosa più importante
che io voglio trasmettere.
Ti ricordi quando sei stato
all'asilo nido,
il contenuto che ti hanno dato?
È molto difficile, vero?
Però di sicuro non hai dimenticato
come ti ha fatto sentire l'insegnante.
E questa è la cosa più importante:
che noi abbiamo la possibilità
di fare sentire molto bene,
con energia molto positiva,
con il corpo, il ritmo, la musica.
E forse, [potremmo farlo]
con una struttura africana,
dove il modello può essere Africa,
e non la Finlandia,
come strumento di lavoro
nella nostra scuola,
nella nostra Università
e in tutta la struttura educativa.
Grazie, è stato un piacere.
(Applausi)